(upbeat instrumental music)
- Welcome to A Conversation
with History, I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is John Harte,
who holds a joint professorship
in the energy and resources group
and the echo system sciences division
of the Colleges of Natural
Resources at UC Berkeley.
He's authored over 150
scientific publications,
including six books.
In 2001, he won the Leo Szilard Award
of the American Physical Society
and he was cited for his
diverse and incisive efforts
using physical reasoning
and analytic tools
for understanding environmental processes
and for his teaching
and writing to encourage
this approach among
students and colleagues.
John, welcome to our program.
- Thank you very much.
- Where we born and raised?
- I was born in New York City,
raised in New York City in the Bronx.
I lived on one of the last
dirt roads of the Bronx
in a little house that's
now sandwiched between
tall apartment buildings.
- Oh my goodness and go ahead please.
- Oh, the house still stands
and I went back to visit
it a few years ago.
- And I'm sure there was
a garden in the back?
- There was, we had a victory garden
during World War Two and it's still there.
- And looking back, how
do you think your parents
shaped you're thinking about the world?
- Well, my parents were
both humanities teachers.
My mother taught English,
my father history
in the public high
schools in New York City
and they certainly imbued me
with a strong love of
literature and art and history
and I've tried to retain
as much of that as I could
and I think my mother forced
on me good writing habits.
I think they gave me a very
strong sense of justice.
They were both active in
teachers unions movements
in New York City
and I think some of my more radical ideas
probably stemmed from them.
- And they sent you to summer camp
from the time you were 10 to about 16,
tell us about that 'cause
that seems to have been
a formative experience.
- It was very formative.
It was a place called Sage Hill Camp
it was in the Green
Mountains of Southern Vermont
and it was a camp with a
bunch of kids from the city
and an old man named Mr. Smith,
who was at the time in his 70s.
There were no formal counselors,
there was no regimented
structure for the day.
We built our own lean
tubes that we slept in.
We did a lot of the maintenance work
and we kind of
self-governed with Mr. Smith
looking out at us and reigning us in
when we got too ornery and mischievous,
but it was a camp that really
taught habits of independence
and I think that was
indeed very formative.
- And you write that you learned from him
not just the names of animals and plants,
but how the pieces fit together.
- Yeah, you know, back in the 1950s
we didn't talk about systems, ecologists,
but if ever there was
one it was Mr. Smith.
He actually had been in his middle years
a forest ranger in
California and he came back
to the east coast from California
just before World War Two
and wanted to do something
to help kids have better
youths, help them grow up,
get out of the city, experience nature,
and so he bought this
chunk of land up in Vermont
and maybe from his forest
ranger experiences in the west
he understood intuitively
the principles of ecology
and I learned a lot from him.
- And you write you were impressed
and one of the things that stayed with you
was his acceptance of the chaos within us
and then you go on to speak of learning
the value of chaos and
continuity under his tutelage.
Explain that.
- Well, what I did, I think
what you're reading from
was a little essay I wrote,
which was kind of an homage
to Mr. Smith and to the camp
and I wrote about the phenomenon
of ecological succession
and it's in that context
that that quote appeared.
After when I was about 16 the camp folded.
The new generation of kids
weren't interested in a camp
where you had to house yourself
and figure out how to spend your day.
They wanted more structured life,
they wanted to sit home in the summer
and watch television or
whatever and the camp folded
and what had been a meadow
in a clearing in the forest
and it originally before
he bought it as a camp
had been a farm, was now
reverting back to the wilderness
that used to be Vermont and
I went back and visited,
oh it was probably about 25 years ago
and I noticed how succession was restoring
some of the wild old-growth
forests in Vermont
that the original seeds
had been left there
and despite the manicured
nature of the farms
when they're deserted and abandoned,
the real wilderness returns and with it
the chaos of the wilderness.
And so we had the return of
the chaos of old-growth forest,
the wildness and the jungle
like atmosphere in it,
but it's a continuity
because it's a recovery
of what used to be
and what I like to think
Mr. Smith understood
is that within each of
us, each of these kids
that were under his tutelage,
there was sort of a
yearning to be wild and free
and he let that come back and
a lot of that had been lost
in some of these kids,
but he helped it recover.
- Tell us a little about
your formal education.
Where you did your undergraduate work,
what your major was
and then where and what
you did on your dissertation.
- I went from public high
school to Harvard college
and at Harvard I went through
a very strange set of transitions.
I went thinking I might
major in English literature
and very interested in creative
writing and I discovered
I think I took my freshman year
a course with Archibald MacLeish
who was on the faculty,
and in my class were juniors and seniors
who were published poets and writers
and I just felt so outclassed by them.
I thought gee, maybe I'm not
as good at this as I think
so I ventured off into history.
My mother's field didn't work,
I thought I'd try my father's
and I realized that I had
some great history teachers.
I took a course from Schlessinger,
it was terrific course,
but again I had this feeling
that maybe that's not
where my real talent is
and when I took math and
physics courses I did well
and I realized okay, I really
do like physics, relativity,
and quantum mechanics are really exciting,
just as exciting as Shakespeare
and I ended up majoring
finally in math and physics.
- And then on to Wisconsin
where you did a theoretical physics--
- Graduate work and got my
PhD in theoretical elementary
particle physics studying the
nature of subatomic particles
and working with various
techniques from theoretical physics
to understand that better
and went from there
on a postdoctoral
fellowship to CERN in Geneva
where there's a huge
atom smasher, psychotron,
and studied there for a
year, wrote several papers,
was able to get a postdoctoral
position at Berkeley
and I spent two years at Berkeley.
I worked under the
advisorship of Jeffrey Chu,
who was on the physics faculty.
He's now retired, but a wonderful man
and worked with him for two years
then took a faculty position at Yale
and was an assistant
professor of physics at Yale
in the physics department,
started in 1968.
And my second year there I
began to get very, very upset
about the Vietnam War like
a lot of my colleagues
and so a colleague and I, Rob Sokolow,
the two of us organized day
of teaching about the war,
not a radical protest, but
a day where we would get
as many students as we
could and as many faculty
to cancel their classes and
we would spend the whole day
hearing seminars on the
Vietnam War and discussing it
and it worked well, we had a huge turnout,
almost all the science
classes were cancelled.
And one of the people
we invited to that event
was Murray Gell-Mann, the
Nobel laureate in physics
who was also a Yale undergraduate,
so he was very happy to come
back to Yale and do this.
Mary Goldburger, the
president of the Institute
for Advanced Study was
there and the two of them
had been hatching a plan
to do a summer study
on some environmental problem.
The idea was to show
that physicists were good
for more than nuclear
physics, that they were
maybe they could do
something and contribute
to this growing thing whatever it was,
we didn't call it an
environmental movement then,
this was before the first Earth Day.
The planning for this
was in the fall of '68
and the event occurred
on March 4th of 1969
and at the dinner that night they asked me
if I'd be interested in
joining a few physicists
and actually work on an
environmental problem
and the problem we chose
was the Everglades.
And there were various
threats to the Everglades,
not the least of which was
a huge jetport being planned
to allow the supersonics that the US
was gonna to build then
to land and take off.
Florida would be the
southern terminus in the US
for all the supersonic flights
to the southern hemisphere
and this would be a huge runway
you need six mile long runways
to land the supersonics
so the idea would be Miami International
was not big enough and so they
would build a new airstrip
right in the middle of the Everglades
and our task was, our self-appointed
task was to figure out
what it would do, how much harm,
and I said sure, I'll do it.
I've always been an avid
birder and Everglade--
- And so they knew you were
in environmental sciences
and you came here then to be
part of energy and resources.
- That's right, I got
totally hooked by the work
in the Everglades, told my
chair of the physics department
at Yale that I wanted to start
an environmental studies program at Yale,
he said not in the physics
department you're not,
so I went to Kingman Brewster
who was president of Yale,
said I'd like to start
an interdisciplinary
environmental studies program.
It actually designed something
that looked a lot like ERG,
and he said "well, I'll
look at it, come back
and see you in a week and
I'll tell you what I think."
So I come back and Brewster said
"you know, at yale we solve
puzzles, not problems.
This isn't the right place,
the right university."
- [Harry] So you came here?
- [John] So I came to Berkeley.
- Now this sets us up to
actually to talk a little about
what are the skills involved
in being an environmental scientist
and also what do you see
as the characteristics
of the man or woman who
does that kind of research?
- Well, I'm a pluralist
about questions like that.
I don't think there's any one
best set of character traits
or intellectual traits.
I think there are a few generalities,
you clearly have to love learning
because whatever you were trained in
no matter how interdisciplinary
your education was
you're gonna discover very quickly
when you confront a new problem
that you need new areas of
scholarship to understand it.
And so one of the things
that appealed to me
when I decided not to stay in physics
was now I had an excuse
to learn about things
like economics, which I had never studied,
to learn about a whole variety of field,
I had actually never
studied much chemistry
even though I was a physics major,
didn't have to take
chemistry, I didn't like it.
But I discovered when I was
looking at environmental issues
that you got to understand chemistry,
had to learn some engineering,
you had to learn a lot more biology
than I had already learned.
And so from the anthropology,
sociology, economic,
you have to keep delving
into those fields--
- So it's really interdisciplinary work,
I mean you wrote a lovely
book, which I'm going to show
and we're going to talk
about The Green Fuse,
which is published by UC Press,
but which is out of print
and which should be reissued,
but you really in talking about
a number of your experiments
and all over the world,
things you've worked at
as an environmental
scientist, what's very clear
is the work is really interdisciplinary.
I mean as soon as you find a problem
and began working on
it, whether it's salmon
or salamanders and
what's happening to them
and what their nitrogen
addition or subtraction
to their local environment,
basically you're moving
from field to field.
- Yeah, in the Everglades
work I had to learn hydrology,
which I had never studied, meteorology,
I'm now pretty well versed
in the science of climate
because I do a lot of
work on how climate change
affects ecosystems, but you
got to understand climate
and it's even more than
just within the sciences.
Soon as I get out into
the world of policy,
which I like to do, I've
had to learn a lot about law
and economics, so being
being a perpetual student
is probably the most important thing.
- And patience was another
thing that I picked up.
Your salamander experiments
went on for 10 years right?
- Yeah, that's right.
Things don't happen
fast and if you look at
only over a year or two you can often see
what you think is a trend or a pattern
and it turns out to be a little blip
in an otherwise very different
long-term trend pattern.
- Now there's a very
interesting interaction,
which is in your discussion
of how an environmental scientist works.
It's often in very local
areas in defined spaces,
but as you unravel whatever
mystery it is you're looking at
you have to stretch the horizon,
so in looking at your career
as conveyed in this journal of
your odyssey The Green Fuse,
you really are moving all over the globe.
You're starting in a locale,
but you're always coming
up against the extent
to which the problems, that
is the damage being done,
are really kind of global
or at least regional issues.
- The thing I most emphasize
with my graduate students
when they start thinking
about their searchable topic
is what's the boundary?
And very often the instinct
is to draw boundaries too tightly.
One has to draw them broadly enough
to encompass everything that's important,
but not too broadly so
that you get mired down
in extraneous detail and the
art of drawing boundaries
around research problems is
something that very few people
just are born understanding,
you have to develop
better and better instincts
for doing that through practice
and I spend a lot of time with my students
on exactly that issue.
- Now when you wrote, when
you won the Szilard award
you gave a talk comparing
the differences between
being a physical scientist
and being an environmental scientist
and we've already just
learned that you've seen life
from both sides now, so let's
talk about that comparison
a little, you know, what's
kind of the difference,
what's the nature of the work,
and what do you conclude
about the difference?
- Yeah, there are two broad
traditions in science,
what I call the Newtonian
and the Darwinian
and they are very different.
Let's start with the Newtonian.
The goal of physics is to
simplify, simplify, simplify,
to find the simple general
law that describes everything
in the universe from
atoms to galactic clusters
and physics has had a
remarkable success record
in doing that and when you start looking
at very fine details they get in the way
of the physicist's goal.
For example, Galileo, who went
up, at least the story goes,
climbed the Leaning Tower
and dropped a heavy object
and a light object down, noted
they fell at the same speed
and discovered the law of inertia that way
and set the stage for all of
Newtonian and modern physics.
Now actually, if that were an ecologist
doing that experiment
he would have noted that the heavy thing
and the light thing fell at
slightly different speeds
because air resistance will be different.
And the ecological worldview
is to be fascinated
by the differences between things.
If I'm studying this
type of frog for 30 years
and that's my life's work,
it's what's different about
that frog that's important,
not what it has in common
with everything else
in the living universe because
if all of it's properties
were in common with everything else,
why bother studying it?
So uniqueness and particularity
characterize ecology
or Darwinian science and
generality and universality
describe Newtonian science.
And what I argued in that essay
is that environmental
issues require a synthesis
of those two worldviews, that
they're not incompatible,
they're not dichotomous, but they reflect
different historical patterns
in the history of science
and that most every really interesting
and important environmental problem,
at least that I've ever
encountered, can't be understood
just from the Newtonian
or just from the Darwinian perspective.
We have to put them together
and I gave some examples in that article.
- And so when you have a student
who has a particular problem
and you're working with them,
you use in this book
examples of the salmon,
which requires you to go to Alaska,
and the salamander, I
believe in The Rockies right?
Yeah, so you have to be ready to pack up
with your backpack in your field.
But that aside,
the problem requires
you to unravel a story
which sort of broadens the horizons
and there's an awful lot
of ambiguity basically
about what is causing
the particular problem
and I think at one
point you say in science
you ask a question and
then the second question
automatically is why are you asking that?
- Yeah, yeah, often,
because if you happen to
like salamanders like I do
it's very natural to ask why
is the population declining?
But the real question has to do
with the broader forces at work.
And for example, we were
documenting how acid rain
was beginning to eradicate
a very unusual population
of salamanders, a
population that was unusual
and whose habitat would had been protected
by the Nature Conservancy
because of this unique
feature of this population--
- Which is that they didn't go--
- Metamorphose--
- Yeah, right.
- And so they're stuck in these lakes
and the lakes get acidic
they're in trouble.
And the interesting thing
is that around that time,
this was in the, we started around 1981
and it was around the time
that I became convinced
that global warming was a real problem,
but I put that worry aside and
I focused on acid deposition.
But then I realized that there's
an even bigger issue here,
which is that under global warming
those ponds won't even exist
even if we reduced acid rain
as we did to a huge extent
with the 1990 Clean Air Act amendments
that applied to western
coal fired power plants.
We cleaned up the rain to a major extent
in that part of of the United States,
but the threat now is an even bigger one,
which is that their entire
habitat is going to disappear
because these ponds will
evaporate to dryness
before the summer ends and so creatures
like these salamanders
that can't metamorphose
'cause they're perpetually
in the larval stage
even when they reproduce,
that they're not going
to have any habitat left
and so the questions
keep, like Chinese boxes,
getting bigger and instead
of going into the box
you're going up to
bigger and bigger boxes.
- And these...
Creatures, is that the appropriate word?
The salamanders in this
case, they're very delicate
and so therefore they are
what you call a green fuse,
a fuse in nature that sounds an alert,
you know, what's happening in the world
and that is very important,
so it's local complexity
leading to a wider and wider circle,
which then moves you into big issues.
- Some people they prefer
the image of the canary
in the mine, but my problem
with the canary image
is when the canary keeled over
the miners would run out of the mine,
but we have no place to run.
We don't have a place to
run to escape the problem
and we have to change the system,
so if the fuse blows, that
there's a systemic problem
that has to be confronted,
that's why I use that image.
And the other thing is that
there are three meanings
of the word fuse and the
book uses all three of them.
- And those three meanings are?
- Well, there's the fuses in
something that leads to a bomb,
you light the fuse, it ticks away
and this is what the
situation with climate,
we're in for an explosively
catastrophic climate
if we don't do anything,
the climate bomb is ticking.
Fuse as in to cohere, to
unite, to put together
and that's where these connections I show
between what's going
on in the Arctic lakes
and what's going on in The Rockies
and what's going on in the Everglades,
that their commonalities,
the threads that tie these places together
and interactions between them.
Teleconnections is a word,
I don't like the word,
but that's a word that
climatologists use to describe this.
If you look at a traditional
nature show on television
this week it's on, you
know, the Brazilian Amazon,
next week it might be
on the Canadian Rockies,
the week after it might
be on the Mediterranean
and each week it's a different place
and you don't learn from those shows
the connections between them.
And what I tried to do in that book
was show the interconnectedness
and so fuse in that sense,
and then finally fuse
in a sense of something
that blows when you've
overloaded the system
and we have overloaded the Earth
and the fuses are starting to pop.
- And it's interesting because
I think it's interesting
at this point to raise the question
of where does creativity come from.
Is it in the midst of this complexity
and the realization is hey,
this answer isn't adequate
because there's a larger picture
or is it imagining
something that isn't there
you say at one point and
wondering why it isn't there?
I think with cypress trees
in the ocean or something.
- Well, there were a couple
of examples, that one was...
I'm trying to think if it was Cypress,
I don't remember the Cypress tree example,
but the creativity comes
from both the sort of
bottom up and the top down.
From the top down it comes
from trying to understand
how to develop ecological
theory that can have
the generality of physics and
the specificity of biology.
There's a tension between those,
that's the issue of unifying
two very different strands
of science history and putting together
new approaches that do that.
This calls for a lot of very creative work
and with my students I think we've made
at least some progress in that.
Then the other source
is the bottom-up source
where you're seeing puzzles in the world.
You're seeing things
that should have been there and weren't.
You're seeing, you know,
the nitrogen levels
behaving in a certain way in Arctic lakes
and then you start to wonder
are the salmon returning from the sea
maintaining these nitrogen supplies
or if it's coming from the alder trees
and the nitrogen-fixing lichen
on the slopes above these Arctic lakes,
will that be impacted by air pollution?
And so you're asking the
technical detailed questions
and then trying to come up
with answers to these puzzles.
It's like detective work.
- And you focus in your
work on three things,
climate change, diversity,
and then sustainable
ecology basically right?
And how have those interests
emerged on your part?
Is it a result of where
the whole field was moving
or do you bump up against those problems
in the different local
environments that you've worked in?
- Well, I let me say that
it would not surprise me
or my colleagues if 10 years from now
I'm doing something different
because if I look back
at how I spent the 1970s
and the 80s and the 1990s
and the last nine years,
been doing different things.
In the 70s when I first came to Berkeley,
I was working on what's
called ecotoxicology,
which is how do toxic
substances affect aquatic life
and ultimately how would
it affect human life?
And I had grants from the
Environmental Protection Agency
to develop better methods for testing
how aquatic ecosystems would
be responding to acid rain,
I'm sorry, to pollution,
and one of the pollutants
I looked at was acidity, that
got me interested in acid rain
and I realized I couldn't
keep studying that in the lab
I had to get out and look
at real lakes and streams
and real ecosystems and so I
began 10 years of field work
on acid deposition and how it affects life
and I was working up in The Rockies,
that was a very good
place to do this work.
But then I realized
toward the end of the 80s
as I mentioned earlier,
that gee, you could solve
the acid rain problem
and climate change would still
wipe these creatures out.
That got me interested
in climate and I ended up
doing a lot of work on how
it affects plant communities,
terrestrial ecosystems,
forests, and meadows
and spent a lot of time on that.
That got me interested in how
ecosystems influence climate.
It's a two-way street,
climate influences ecosystems
but as you change ecosystems
that can alter climate,
that's called feedback,
and I began studying
the feedback effects by
which ecological changes,
whether or not they're brought
about by climate change
will affect climate, and
so lately I've been doing
a lot of work in that area
and then also in the biodiversity area.
I've been interested in trying to develop
fundamental ecological
theory that will help us
better understand
patterns in the abundance
and distribution of species.
- Now...
As we saw in the early
parts of your career,
science was bumping up
against public policy
in the sense that
scientists were concerned
about the Vietnam War and
then later the nuclear buildup
in the nuclear arms race.
And then when you start your work
you're in the Everglades
and then you're bumping up again
the building of a new airport
and this leads you to an analysis
of what makes the Everglades tick.
And one has to then
come to the realization
that the Everglades are
very dependent on swamps
and on this phenomena of
moral, which you could explain,
but, so then how do you
get into the policy?
What is the responsibility
of the scientist?
- We went to Florida, we
began the study thinking
we can show that this
huge planned development
in the Everglades was going
to harm the alligators
and the wood storks and all
of the wonderful creatures
in the Everglades, that
would be reason enough
to convince the public to stop it.
Well, halfway through that study
I realize that's not
going to do the trick,
that there is such huge economic forces
behind this push to build
the supersonics airport there
that we had to come up with something more
and I didn't know if we could.
But I began thinking about
the hydrology of South Florida
and alligators and wood storks
aside, draining the swamps,
even if it didn't harm creatures,
which of course it would,
but even if it didn't,
it was going to destroy
the water supply of half a
million people in South Florida,
not because they're drinking swamp water,
they're drinking well water,
but what's keeping that well water fresh
and not sea line?
It's the swamp water that sits above it
and you drain the swamps and the sea water
comes into the wells.
And we showed that, we demonstrated it
with physical principles.
We put together maps of the aquifer system
and were able to show that
there was a threat looming here
to about half a million people
living along the Gulf Coast
of southern Florida and
that was the argument
that caused them to cancel the plan
to put the airport there.
Now later it turned out that
we never built the supersonics
and the need for that airport dissolved
and instead when they
had to build more runways
and expand airports they just
expanded Miami International.
But at the time, it was that
argument about water supply
to people that ultimately did the trick
and so one of the things
I've learned over the years
is that I love nature,
plants, birds, everything,
but to really make an argument
that will persuade policymakers,
you often have to extend
the analysis and show
how real immediate material
human needs won't be met
when you go ahead and, you
know, destroy something
as beautiful as the Everglades.
- And you have a very strong
sense that the scientist
has a responsibility not
to abuse his own evidence
because he's compelled by
making the political point
which is the right thing he thinks to do
and how do you do that?
I mean where does that
scrupulousness come from
and what have you learned
from employing it?
- I think it comes from,
and maybe this is where
the sense of history that I
got from my father comes in,
that important as the thing
you're currently working on
may seem, it's not the
most important thing.
The problems we're going to
face 20, 30, 40 years from now
could be much more important
than they are today.
And if I go all out and
twist and distort the science
in order to get the public to do something
about a current problem,
I may sufficiently destroy
the reputation of science
or at least my reputation,
but it actually undermines all of science
when people do this and
makes it more difficult
for my young students
coming out now in 20 years
to attack the problems
they're gonna confront,
so it's this feeling that we're always
going to have problems
and we can't pull the rug
out from under the future
by distorting the present.
We have to be as honest
and careful as we can today
in order to protect the
institution of science
because we're going to need
that institution in the future.
- Now this raises an interesting point
which is what exactly are
your philosophical assumptions
beyond just your
assumptions as a scientist
about how you work?
And one thing that's very important
is factoring in the consequences
for future generations.
Talk about that because
that's really central
to what you just said,
which is not undermining
the reputation of science in the future.
- Well, maybe coming from
mathematics and physics
I have this appreciation
for the logic of something
like the categorical imperative,
the Kantian ethical principle
is based on a kind of irrefutable logic,
but it's missing something.
And what it's missing
is something I realized
and probably stems from some
philosophical belief system
I have, although I'm not sure
I could characterize it real well,
but it's that, two
things: the future is...
It's just as important as the president.
There's a wonderful statement
that summarizes this
I didn't think of this,
but it's a lovely phrase
I quoted in the book.
Herman Daly, the economist,
who has fought this notion
that if an economy doesn't grow it dies.
He's really the parent of the concept
of a steady-state economy.
He once had to write a
review of a just awful book
by Julian Simon that was another economist
who believed that there
were no limits to growth
and Simon wrote we should
try to have as many people
on this planet as we can.
People are good so let's have more of them
and Daly writing a
review of the book said,
he began the review in a
way that startled many of us
when we read it he began by saying
"Yes, I agree with Simon,
we should have as many people
on this planet as possible,
but not all at the same time."
And it's a beautiful statement.
Let's keep the enterprise
going for as long as possible
rather than try to puff it
up as much as we can today.
And that I think is, or lard
it up as much as we can today,
that reflects a philosophical
view that I share
and so in extending the Kantian imperative
to future generations,
which is what I talk about
in the epilogue in the
book, I'm reflecting,
I think something that I feel ready,
but I have no idea why I think
it or where it came from,
but the other thing I feel very strongly,
and again this in a way started
coming into consciousness
with the Everglades study,
is that there's been a progression
and long ago people used to say
man is the steward of nature and that idea
is considered in advance over the notion
that man is the ruler of nature
that we should be more like a shepherd
with his flock than
like a vindictive ruler.
But, I don't think that goes far enough
the idea of man is the steward of nature.
I really believe nature
is the steward of us
and that...
The human economy is a
wholly owned subsidiary
of natural ecosystems.
Without the ecosystem
services they provide
the whole human enterprise is over
and so I feel very strongly
that we should view
our relationship to nature that way
rather than as we are somehow
governing and stewarding.
- And one of the mistakes
we make you write
is not recognizing that nature
requires restraint from us.
If the human impulse is to dam the rivers,
hack the forests, blast out the mountains,
and scour the rivers for metal ores,
drain the wetlands, and
pollute the rain and snow
is given free reign in
the western mountains,
then our children and
all future generations
will not be blessed with
these gifts of nature.
That's a real redefinition isn't it
that we're going to have to adjust to?
- Yeah, I think when we
talk about conservation
I think what we really
have to pull back on
is our urge to do everything
we know how to do.
There are many things
we could do if we wanted
and we have to restrain those urges.
- Now what is the implication of this
for our commitment to capitalism?
Because recently Gus
Speth was on our program
from Yale and he was arguing in that book
after a whole career in
the environmental movement,
he had come to realize both in government
and outside of government that capitalism
was part of the problem.
- Well, fortunately we've
never really tried capitalism.
We have some modified
sort of Mongrel system
with some elements of
capitalism and fortunately,
many elements of regulation and control.
We've seen in the current economic crisis
that our controls and regulations
aren't always adequate, strong enough.
Pure unadulterated capitalism
would be an absolute disaster.
Fortunately, I don't know
of any modern society
that's ever tried it, but it
would be an utter disaster
and the people who would hate it the most
would be the CEOs of major companies.
Think where the oil industry would be
without the subsidies and the regulations
and the military apparatus
that makes possible
what they do overseas.
So no, we don't have
capitalism thank goodness.
What I believe is that we need
a more well-regulated economy
with more government regulation,
particularly to protect us from things
like inefficient and
excess use of fossil fuels
when we could be at actually
at an economic advantage
to ourselves be replacing
fossil fuels with renewables
and particularly with
more energy efficiency.
- It would seem that one
of the things obviously
strangely and ironically
the economic collapse
becomes an opportunity to reconsider
the way we do things in
our relation to capitalism
our relationship to nature,
but I'm curious with your long experience
you've been in, you've
contributed to law journals,
you've worked on issues of land use
and it's obviously very complicated
how you resolve some of the dilemmas.
I'm curious it would seem
that there's an important
role for political education
for educating people about the science
as a path to educating them
about the social choices
we have to make.
- That's exactly right.
One of the things I enjoyed teaching
a class I taught this fall
during the the worsening
of the economic situation
was how we can look
at the human economy the way an ecologist
looks at the feedbacks in an ecosystem.
And within our economic
system, we've rigged it
so that there are these
positive cascading feedbacks,
not positive in that they're good for us,
positive in that they're amplifying,
and so something starts to go wrong
that triggers a response that
triggers a counter response
and then the end result
is that you've exacerbated
the original triggering causes
and made the situation worse.
And so we descend, so we
spiral down into true recession
which is where I think we are now
and I think political
scientists need to hear
how ecologists view these problems
and understand this systems approach
to thinking about the economy
in the broad sense of the term,
not just the monetary economy
but the whole structure of governance.
- Is this a generational thing?
I mean obviously you've
just walked us through
how you came to see the
importance of ecology
and environment and the
turns that you took,
so the question is is there a kind
of an environmental
consciousness that you see
among a broader sweep of students,
a growing and sort of
growing that actually will
at a certain point have political impact?
- Yeah and I think it's been documented,
but not by me, but by people
who do opinion polling
and sociologists who
have conducted surveys
and the young kids coming
out of grade school now
know so much more about
how the world really works.
Back when I was a kid nobody was taught
where food comes from or how climate
influences our well-being
or any of this stuff.
Partly we figured it
out, partly we went back
and back into history
and read accounts of how,
like Jared Diamond's book Collapse,
and we learned about the connections
between the natural world
and the world of people and society.
But today I think students
are learning much more
about this as they come out of school
and so when students now come into
our graduate program they
often know in a factual sense
as much as I do about the
problems that the world faces.
What they're lacking often
are the analytical tools
to go deeper and understand deeper causes
and especially solutions,
so that's where we can provide
a good training I think.
- One of the chapters
in The Green Fuse book
is a visit to China and
there you touch upon an issue
that we have to put on the table
namely this whole question
of these late comers
to development and the consequences
of their following our erroneous paths
for global development.
Now you were involved in the
anti-nuclear build-up movement
and I know, so give us your insight
into how this kind of
international dynamic works
either between environmental
scientists across the globe,
but beyond that to kind
of global governments.
- I think what a number of us
in the environmental movement are doing
whether we think about
it consciously or not
is actually trying to
save developing countries
from a path that will prevent development,
destroy their quality of
life, and wreck their economy,
namely a path that looks just like the one
we in the west took.
There's a better way to do it.
If they try to do what we did
they're not going to get
to our standard of living.
You just can't do that with
the available resources
and the high population densities
that now affleck Africa,
China, India, you have to do it better.
And what we're trying to say
is that what we should
be doing in the west
is also what they should
be doing in the south
and the east, namely
developing sustainable
renewable resources, solar and wind,
not oil and coal and natural gas.
Those are vulnerable sources,
they're gonna get more and more expensive,
they're going to foul the air,
they're going to destroy the climate.
What we need to do is
develop ourselves better
by replacing the dirty energy sources
that led to our development
with cleaner ones
and see the developing
countries do the same.
And what I'd love to see,
my dream is an economic
arms race if you like
between the solar developers
and the wind turbine
developers in China and India
and the south and our own
renewable energy developers.
Who is gonna be the John D. Rockefeller
of the second half of this century?
Who are going to be the corporate giants?
It's not going to be the people
pulling oil out of the ground.
Rockefeller did what he did
because it was a long time ago
and you could do it then.
Now it's going to be the people
who come up with the most cost effective
energy sources that are
clean and voluminous enough
to really make a difference.
And if you look actually,
China is a world leader
in solar panel development.
China and Germany are the two leaders,
we should be, but we're not.
I'm hoping with the
transition in Washington
that we will soon get back on that path
and start competing with
the rest of the world.
If we don't, we're on the
outside, we're gonna lose
and the economic giants of
the second half this century
will be the countries and the corporations
that have the wisdom to invest
in these kind of developments.
- Let's talk briefly about global warming.
It's an enormous topic, but we've gone
here we have people like
you warning us decades ago
that this problem was emerging,
we've had in the last eight years,
I guess one could say, science locked up
in Vice President Cheney's safe--
- [John] A lock box.
- That's right, that's right,
so now we have an administration
that's ready to move.
What would you like to see happen?
Obviously, these are long-term problems.
Today we're doing this
interview in late January,
report is issued saying that it may be
the carbon deposits may be irreversible
or the damage that's being done
even if we reduce the carbon,
what would you like to see
the new administration do?
- I'm glad you asked.
My wife and I have actually written a book
and it's available free
online, there's a website,
it could be a big article
about it in the...
Berkeleyan, is that the name, the weekly?
- [Harry] Yeah, the campus paper, yeah.
- Coming out I think this week--
- It will when we put this interview up
we'll link to it, yeah.
- What we do is describe,
the first two chapters
present to the layperson
a clear simple explanation
of global warming and why the
science is utterly believable
and why we should be concerned
and why we need to take action.
The next nine chapters
talk about what to do
and we present a complete coherent plan,
the technology, the
economics, and the policy
for achieving a solution.
And we do this, by the way,
without any carbon sequestration
because I not persuaded
that it's plausible
to sequester carbon and we do it
without a large commitment to biofuels
because I'm very concerned
about the competition
for land between food,
which we're going to need
more and more of in the
future as population grows
and land for biofuels, so no biofuels,
no carbon sequestration,
nuclear we don't require it,
it's there, but we're not
asking for an expansion of it.
We rely on efficiency, wind, solar,
and some geothermal, a lot of efficiency.
You had an interview with Amory Lovins
and so you've probably
got a good exposure--
- Yeah, and re-engineering required, yeah.
- That's right, the huge
amount of fat in our system
that can be cut out with efficiency gains.
And the policy measures
include regulations
to impose higher and higher
fuel efficiency standards on automobiles.
We can easily get to 60
or 70 mile per gallon
by the year 2025 if we tell the automakers
they have to do it.
If we don't tell them
to do it, they won't,
but if we do, they must.
And so fuel efficiency
standards for automobiles
and for homes, new homes,
appliance standards for air conditioners,
refrigerators, and stoves and so forth.
Then I want to, this is one
of the more radical pieces
of the plan, one way to think about
what we're asking for is
that we treat solar and wind
the way we now treat oil.
We hugely subsidize oil.
In fact, the Iraq war, which
some people would argue
is an oil subsidy because
it was a major motivation
for the war, is going to
cost over a trillion dollars.
imagine what you could do
with a trillion dollars
spent on solar and wind
turbines to produce electricity.
We could wean ourselves
off of all of our coal
and about three-quarters of our oil.
We still need some for some
liquid fuels for aircraft
and so on, but the replacing
current automobiles
with rechargeable hybrids
and getting the electricity
to charge them from wind and sun.
How do we get society to go there?
Well, shifting subsidies
and then I want to take
that foolish tax cut that
Bush gave the wealthy
and I want to keep that as a tax cut,
but not for the wealthy.
I want to make it a tax cut,
a tax break on the profits
from the sale of clean energy.
There's a motivation for people
to invest in clean energy.
It doesn't pick winners in advance
because if you're not selling clean energy
'cause you didn't invent the right device
you don't get the tax cut,
so it's a tax cut that
automatically targets the winners
and from what I can
understand of investment
and technology and economics,
such a tax shift would cause a flood
of investment money into
the clean energy sector
and the combination of shifting subsidies,
shifting that tax break, and regulations,
we wouldn't even need a carbon tax,
which I think is politically
a very tall order.
I don't think it's gonna be easy
to get a carbon tax in place,
so we don't need it if
we do all these things.
- What is the title of the book
so that people can google
it if it's available--
- The website where you can
do a free download of the book
is www.cooltheearth, all
one word, cooltheearth.us
- And I think our audience
will want to read that
and it can serve as a guide as they watch
the new administration move forward,
but then maybe backward as
it feels political pressure.
- And the title of the book is
Cool The Earth, Save The Economy:
Solving Global Warming Is Easy, EASY
and the E is for efficiency,
the A is for the automobile,
the S is for solar, and the
Y is for you and you and you.
It's for all the things we have
to do as individual citizens
to complete the four
parts of the strategy.
- [Harry] Any you co-authored this--
- With my wife--
- [Harry] And her name is?
- Mary Ellen Harte.
- So the Hartes are giving us something
that we need to look at and then,
so John, before I thank you
I want to show this book
which I read for this interview,
it's called The Green
Fuse: An Ecological Odyssey
and our audience will discover
that it's out of print,
but I'm sure that they
can write to UC Press
and invite them to reissue it
or at least put it on in digital format
so others can get to it.
So on that note, I want
to thank you for taking us
on this intellectual odyssey
'cause it's really
helped us to think about
the opportunities that
we're now presented with
with a new administration.
Thank you very much.
- [John] Thank you very much.
- And thank you very much for joining us
for this Conversation with History.
(upbeat instrumental music)